most of what the scp foundation contains
are things you would rightfully prefer
to keep locked up after all not many
people want to be torn to shreds by
scp-096
tortured by
scp-106 eaten up by scp-082 or driven
mad by the sheer power and evil of the
scarlet king most scps are so cruel or
dangerous that a run-in with even a cute
little teddy bear could spell your doom
but what about the other side of the
coin what about the scp objects you
don't just want to avoid but actually
have in your possession to see
to use as you see fit that my friends is
exactly what we're here to discuss today
the scp objects you'd actually want no
hidden catches no nightmarish side
effects no curses or strings attached
think of it almost like an anomalous
skymall catalog
these are all the scps you never knew
you wanted but would happily break into
an scp foundation containment facility
to obtain speaking of breaking into
places let's start our odyssey of
desirable anomalies with scp-005
you ever forgotten or lost your keys and
been locked out of your house or maybe
you've wanted to get a backstage pass to
your favorite concert without spending a
dime heck ever wanted to rob a bank or
steal a million dollars in gold from
fort knox don't worry we're not here to
judge in fact we're going to tell you
how to make those dreams come true what
you need is the skeleton key as you can
probably tell from the name the skeleton
key is a normal if a little
old-fashioned looking key that can open
literally any lock on earth the white
house no problem the pentagon piece of
cake buckingham palace you can stroll
right in and try on all the queen's
finest jewelry though of course if you
have no interest in becoming a master
infiltrator and instead just want a
little more convenience in your daily
life the skeleton key also makes life
easier by making you only need one key
for your house your car your bike lock
any lock at all think of all the pocket
space you'll save the possibilities are
endless speaking of endless the next
item on the list gives a whole new
meaning to the phrase all you can eat
are you feeling hungry are you part of
the strong 95 of the human population
that loves pizza then buddy you're going
to love
scp-458 also known as the limitless
pizza box if the name alone hasn't sold
you then trust us it's going to get even
more appealing the anomaly is a large
size pizza takeout box from the little
caesars pizza chain and not only can
this box produce a truly endless
quantity of pizza it also has an
intuitive psyche connection with whoever
is using it are you a devotee of chicago
style deep dish you got it do you prefer
more of a cheesy new york style slice
with a little parmesan sprinkled on top
order up or maybe you're a real
traditionalist and like a pure italian
no cheese with a sprinkling of olives by
sano this box has got you covered if you
love pizza then scp-458 is a must-have
for your kitchen so let's say
hypothetically you've just eaten six
pepperoni pizzas from
scp-458 dishes are piled high in the
sink and you know they need to be
cleaned but you're in too much of a food
coma to get up and do anything if only
you could just ring a little bell and
summon someone who would happily do all
those stupid chores for you but alas
such a thing is impossible right well
you'll be delighted to learn that this
is very possible with scp-662
also known as the butler's handbell with
a simple little ring you'll summon the
hyper-helpful british butler mr deeds an
entity who literally lives to serve from
doing your laundry to giving you foot
rubs to assassinating that one jerk at
your office who always steals your
pudding cups from the fridge mr deeds
will endeavor to complete almost any
request within the realms of physical
possibility if you've ever wanted to lie
back and have someone else take care of
all those pesky responsibilities that
make up the big to-do list that is life
then
scp-662 is your must-have anomalous
ticket to freedom but maybe you don't
need a supernatural butler to do
everything for you you're
self-sufficient you take pride in doing
things for yourself but you feel a
little down and you could really use
some encouragement from someone else
close to you it's times like these when
you could really use a few words from a
father who is no longer in your life to
get you feeling confident again if this
applies to you then you'll definitely
want to get your hands on
scp-348 also known as a gift from dad
this wholesome soup bowl appears to be a
spiritual conduit to a loving fatherly
figure producing the ultimate comfort
food that will cure minor ailments and
leave you with a sense of happiness and
peace its effects may not be as amazing
as some of the other big ticket items on
this list but it's definitely one of the
most feel-good scp objects out there and
sure would be nice to have on hand for
days when you need it speaking of
feeling good what feels better than
being in love especially when the person
you're in love with is just perfect for
you and loves you back just as much the
problem is in a world as big and
complicated as ours who knows where your
true love is waiting to be found if you
can feel yourself longing for the love
of your life then you need scp-2203
also known as find the right one for you
this device is a standard love tester
machine the kind that were a lot more
common in bars a couple decades ago but
this is a love tester unlike any other
when you use the machine it doesn't give
you a rating from cold fish to casanova
instead it dispenses a small card with a
name and address on it which just so
happens to be the name and address of
your true love it even features advice
on how to initially approach and woo the
potential person of your dreams for the
socially awkward and hopelessly romantic
this machine feels heaven-sent just
remember once you're actually in the
relationship it's up to you to be a good
partner if you want to make it last
scp-2203 can't help you with that part
we're afraid of course an important part
of being a romantic partner or even just
a good friend is being attentive to the
other person's needs but to meet those
needs you first need to understand them
and wouldn't it be great to know
someone's deepest desires without having
to go through the trouble of actually
asking allow us to introduce you to
scp-978
also known as the desire camera this
simple polaroid camera allows the user
to peer into the very hearts of their
subjects all you need to do is take a
photograph of them and the resulting
polaroid picture will reveal whatever
their deepest desire happens to be
whether it's a trip to an amusement park
a new tie or to reconnect with their
estranged father keith is it a little
creepy to pry into someone's most
private thoughts like this without them
knowing absolutely in fact it's super
creepy but hey what they don't know
won't hurt them right maybe all this
violating the privacy of your closest
loved ones has worked up a powerful
thirst in you but you don't just want
any old cup of joe maybe you want to
have the exact cup of coffee you had at
a now closed diner in 1995
or maybe you want to know what a liquid
dream tastes like or perhaps you just
need a cup of anti-freeze for your car
and really don't feel like going to the
hardware store to get some
if this describes you then you need to
get your hands on
scp-294 deceptively known as the coffee
machine we say deceptively because this
anomaly is so much more than a coffee
machine with a little pocket change and
the electronic keypad connected to it
you can order any liquid you desire even
things that don't traditionally come as
liquids no matter your thirst you can
satisfy it with the help of
scp-294 of course there is the possible
downside of ordering something dangerous
or deadly and then drinking it but
frankly that would be more your fault
than scp-294's
remember to read the warning labels kids
maybe you've ordered an alien energy
drink from scp-294 and it really isn't
sitting well with you you can feel your
liver withering away inside of you and
even if you call an ambulance you're not
sure that it'll get here in time to save
you it's starting to go dark is this the
end no because lucky for you you took
the time to acquire scp-2295
also known as the best bear a name that
this plush creature has more than earned
you see this bear is the world's
smallest yet most competent trauma
surgeon if ever someone collapses with
organ failure within two meters of this
magnanimous little bear it will create a
perfect functional organ from nearby
materials like yarn and string to
replace the broken one and then perform
a flawless life-saving surgery on its
patients if ever you worry your organs
are on the fritz then you'll be glad
that you can count
scp-2295 among your personal possessions
also when your organs aren't failing
nobody can deny that it's nice to have a
cute little teddy bear around to cuddle
but what if you don't want a little bear
or a magic butler to solve all of your
problems maybe you want to be a little
more self-sufficient and gain the
knowledge and skills vital to live the
life you want to live if this applies to
you then you're going to adore scp-5094
also known as miss jay's whiz kid
schoolhouse this software which comes on
a cd-rom is the ultimate find for the
lifelong learner anyone who has the
program can be personally tutored by
miss j the perfect digital teacher on
almost any subject they can possibly
imagine want to become an expert in
advanced thermonuclear physics want to
be able to memorize every single one of
shakespeare's works to a letter want to
know everything a human being could
possibly know about cats have no fear
miss jay has your back with her
trademark intensive courses she can turn
novices into experts in just a few days
leaving you feel enriched by the
knowledge you've just been exploring if
expanding your mind and your horizons on
a regular basis with the best teacher in
the world sounds like a dream come true
to you then
scp-1594 will be an scp object you'd
kill to get your hands on metaphorically
speaking of course miss j would never
condone violence after all after a hard
day of hitting the books or computer
screen you're going to need a snack but
not just any snack you want one that's
out of this world or maybe even out of
this dimension it's time to pay a visit
to scp-261
also known as the interdimensional
vending machine this vending machine
randomly generates exciting snacks and
drinks from all across the multiverse
including fruits of the loom a package
of three pieces of edible underwear in
fun bright colors and rat on a stick
which is well exactly what it sounds
like and finally what do you get for the
person who has everything else the best
gift of all the gift of life there are
still plenty of diseases that even the
scp foundation has not been able to cure
except with one extremely rare and
extremely special anomalous item
scp-500 also known as the panacea the
scp is a bottle containing a small
number of pills capable of curing any
ailment known to man from alzheimer's to
the flesh that hates when it comes to
healing there is no equal to scp-500
and considering you'll be drinking
inter-dimensional soft drinks and eating
truly disgusting amounts of pizza it's
never a terrible idea to have a cure for
cardiac arrest laying around and there
you have it folks a list of the scp
objects you actually want the hardest
part is going to be breaking into the
heavily guarded foundation containment
sites to get them in the first place but
hey we can cross that bridge when we get
to it which one of these objects do you
think are worth the risk of getting shot
at by mobile task forces for let us know
in the comments now go check out the
ipods
scp-131 and
scp-1609 remains of a chair for more scp
objects you wouldn't mind having in your
life